When we interpolate the red, green, and blue colors across a triangle, we get
this result. It's important to understand how the triangle rasterization part of
the pipeline actually interpolates across the triangle. Essentially, whatever is
put at one vertex fades off across the triangle. For example, say, instead of
putting rgb, we put green at the top corner, and black at the other two corners.
You can see in this case that the green is the brightest at the corner, and then
fades as we approach the other two corners. If you think of green as represented
by one, and black as zero, we linearly interpolate across the triangle and fade
from one to zero. This works for the other two corners in a similar fashion,
with blue fading to black as shown here. For comparison here's the red
component. Since light is additive, the GPU uses all three of these components
to display the triangle. The GPU will interpolate any data put at its vertices
in this way, effect we'll use later for material shading.